let's talk about what's happening in the
West Bank because violence there has
been getting a lot worse While most of
the attention has been on the war in the
Gaza
Strip there have been more raids by the
Israeli military more arrests and more
Palestinians
killed there is a great sense of fear
and tension here because these raids are
happening every single night armed
Israeli settlers have been attacking
Palestinians and driving entire
communities off their
land so what exactly is the West Bank
what's going on there right now and how
does it tie into what's happening in
Gaza the West Bank gets its name because
it's the West Bank of the River Jordan
it's part of the Palestinian territories
that have been occupied by Israel since
1967 around 2.8 million Palestinians
live there down here is Gaza which is
run by Hamas but in the West Bank the
Palestinian Authority or PA is in charge
partially at least the PA is led by
President Mahmud abas who's been getting
a lot of criticism from Palestinians for
being weak and ineffective now the West
Bank is divided into three
administrative zones in area a the PA
controls things like health educ and the
economy it's in charge of internal
security too in area b control is shared
between the PA and Israel then there's
area C the biggest Zone which is under
full Israeli control it's where Israel
has built many illegal settlements and
it's where we're seeing that Spike and
settler attacks against Palestinians
right now more on all of that in a bit
now even though you've got these three
different zones remember that Israel is
the occupying power across the whole
West Bank and in the end that trumps
everything the Israeli Army can and does
enter all Palestinian communities and
cities including those that the PA is
supposed to have complete control over I
am a 27 year old I never vote for
anything in my life all my life I've
been controlled by M16s that hold by
Israeli soldiers I don't have any CI
civil rights any life requirements about
our life we have to ask a military a
foreign military that controls our life
Israel's occupation of the West Bank has
all sorts of consequences for
Palestinians restrictions on their
movement and access to their land are a
major part of it since 1967 Israel has
built more than 130 settlements that
include homes and infrastructure for
Israeli citizens they're considered
illegal under international law these
settlements are connected by roads that
carve up Palestinian land and some of
the roads are only open to people with
Israeli license plates the West Bank is
also fragmented by Israel's huge
separation wall which eats into more
Palestinian territory there are also
hundreds of military checkpoints that
Palestinians have to pass through to
move around in the West Bank or to cross
into Israel and often people need
Israeli travel permits Palestinians
experience Israeli occupation in
different ways in the West Bank there
are different levels of uh Siege and
blockade if you will there are Villages
that are completely isolated by Gates
and walls there are other communities
that have easier access in and out of of
their communities uh but overall any
movement of Palestinians or Palestinian
Goods is strictly governed by the
Israeli Army so in a way you
have many different prisons in within
the the West Bank the door and the and
the key is with the Israeli army they
can lock them up and open them up at
will after October 7th life in the West
Bank has become even more restricted
that's when Hamas Fighters attacked
Israel and Israel responded with a
massive assault on
[Music]
Gaza the Army also locked down many
parts of the West Bank it's almost
impossible for people to move from one
city to another the Israeli Army
immediately fragmented Palestinian
cities so they made sure that the
southern W West Bank is disconnected
from the north the UN has reported cases
of women having to give birth at
checkpoints because of the
closures life in the West Bank has also
become more dangerous even before
October 7th 2023 was the deadliest year
for Palestinians in the West Bank since
2008 199 people were killed by Israeli
forces and Israeli settlers since
October 7th more than 120 people have
been killed including more than 30
children what's behind those numbers
it's mainly Israeli military raids and
settler attacks attack s the Israeli
Army has stepped up raids what they call
counterterrorism Operations especially
in places like
Janine Janine has for many many years
been a center for the armed resistance
here in the occupied West Bank there are
various different factions various
different groups a lot of weapons there
have been a lot of arrests and there
have been a number of people killed here
since the beginning of the war and the
situation has got a lot worse when you
talk to people here their reaction as to
why for example this was done here on a
street where they say there were no
clashes there were no kids throwing
stones it was a quiet quiet night last
night and this bulldozer just came in
and dug this road up and of course they
call it a form of collective punishment
those raids are also um in a way part of
the way Israel maintains control by
telling reminding everybody who boss
right reminding everybody that they can
enter Homes at night they can detain
people and a lot of people have been
detained around 2,000 according to the
Palestinian Authority Israel says it's
rounding up Hamas members and supporters
but Palestinians would tell you that
they're also rounding up anyone who
shows solidarity uh towards Gaza on
social media or publicly most of these
the people who are detained are detained
without charge and they're held without
charge or trial they're called
administrative detainees it's one more
mechanism of maintaining control over
the the population so that paints a
picture of the way that Israeli forces
operate in the west bank and then
there's the
settlers they're the people living in
the Israeli settlements many of them are
there because of an ideology that's all
about increasing Jewish presence on
Palestinian land many are armed and
settlers routinely threaten and attack
Palestinians now they're a bit more
emboldened by the fact that there's a
war and their violence is much more
considerable and much more lethal
settler related incidents which is what
the UN calls them have more than doubled
since October 7th these incidents
include settlers putting up roadblocks
to prevent Palestinians from accessing
their land vandalizing Palestinian
properties setting cars on
fire and injuring and killing
Palestinians like Bal Salah who was shot
dead while harvesting olives on his land
in this video you can see armed settlers
in the field where Bal was killed in
other incidents Palestinians say
settlers showed up in military
uniform settlers also get protection
from the Israeli Army almost half of all
incidents since October 7th have
involved Israeli forces accompanying or
actively supporting Israeli settlers
while carrying out the
[Music]
attacks crosses the barrier and
tentatively starts walking towards his
olive trees Israeli soldiers near the
hilltop settler Outpost begin descending
the slope towards him an armored vehicle
moves down the road all of this violence
and intimidation puts pressure on
Palestinians to leave their homes and
their land according to the UN more than
800 Palestinians have been displaced in
this way in the West Bank since the war
in
Gaza in this Village 141 people packed
up and left their homes after settlers
threatened to kill them if they didn't
the ultimate goal the coveted prize for
the Israeli settler movement is the West
Bank is making sure that this area this
land is vacated from its indigenous
population of the of Palestinians um and
is permanently and and irreversibly
annexed to Israel this ideology is
backed by people in top positions within
the Israeli government like the national
security minister itamar benir who's a
West Bank settler himself in the days
after the October 7 attacks benir said
his ministry was buying 10,000 rifles to
arm civilians including in West Bank
settlements over the years what we've
seen is Israeli politics going to the
right appeasing these settler groups
appeasing their appetite for more land
appeasing their hostility towards
Palestinians and entrenching impunity
we're just you know Farmers trying to
plant cultivate our land and to live
from what we produce what we can do to
face those settlers who are fully
weaponed with machine guns protected by
the Army and back backed by the
government and their leaders in the
government the violence in the West Bank
is getting some attention Israel's
biggest Ally the US has condemned the
recent settler attacks I continue to be
alarmed about extremist settlers
attacking Palestinians in the West Bank
that uh pouring gasoline on fire is what
it's like it has to stop they have to be
held accountable the truth of the matter
is these statements even though they
reflect facts really don't amount to
anything because Israel understands that
they would not be uh accompanied with
consequences 5 days after Biden's
statement the Israeli defense minister
said this
Mission the attacks haven't stopped
and this kind of violence has been going
on for years and the people behind it
are almost never held accountable all
these attacks that are very well
documented um face no
consequence so barely any of them get
investigated and almost none of them end
up in criminal Pro uh prosecution even
even if they result in the physical harm
of Palestinian civilians or even the
death
what we've got right now is a really
volatile situation in the West Bank
while the war in Gaza rages on and a lot
of people are worried about where all
this could
lead we do a lot of explainers on start
here about current events you can watch
all of our episodes on this YouTube
[Music]
playlist